et puis à six semaines des jo de tokyo
et trois ans avant ceux de paris
plusieurs villes organisant ce moment
des semaines olympiques
or les ans des rencontres entre écoliers
athlètes sont au programme mais pas
seulement ce matin des enfants montent
assister à une démonstration de saut à
la perche avec stan est joseph cet
athlète orléanais a notamment participé
aux jo de rio en 2016
il était là pour transmettre son idéal
olympique aux plus jeunes écoutent et
moi du coup j'ai participé aux jeux
olympiques en 2016 donc j'ai quelque
chose à transmettre aussi et ça me fait
vraiment plaisir de le transmettre à la
en plus sûr aujourd'hui on va le faire
de manière en extérieur en plein air
grandeur nature je pense que les enfants
ils n'ont pas l'occasion tous les jours
de voir des sur la perche d'aussi près
donc oui je sais un plus et ça fait
partie ça fait partie du métier aussi
quoi mais moi je si je peux rendre un
petit peu au sport si tout ce qu'il m'a
donné tout ce qui m'a permis de vivre
voilà c'est moi je le fais volontiers et
puis sinon c'est quelque chose de bien
je trouve